berlin's cloyd's back district is well
known for its many cafes restaurants and
bars it's also one of the German
capitals most ethnically mixed areas
once a counterculture hotbed it's now a
magnet for hipsters from all over the
world courts beg is also home to the
restaurant yo leche which specializes in
austrian cuisine the head chef is to be
as handsome now the Italian classic
spaghetti all'amatriciana has been added
to the menu yo lish is taking part in a
campaign started by italian blogger
paolo campana on a facebook post on
august 25th he asked restaurants to
serve the dish in a show of solidarity
with earthquake victims in America Italy
star chefs like Jamie Oliver and over
700 restaurants around the world have
answered the call to euros are donated
for every portion sold
come to cool the campaign has met with a
very good response people like to eat
spaghetti and if they can do something
good it tastes all the better Sofie
vissa in the nearby market hall 9 Tobias
Johnson collects the ingredients for the
recipe the most essential one is the
pasta from noodle makers money in Costa
they make their organic spaghetti fresh
every day pasta allometry Chiana uses
just a few ingredients so it's important
that they be the very best the pasta
comes from a special fifty thousand euro
machine add goes to restaurants and
hotels throughout Berlin in the region
next on the list from a vegetable stand
close by are the onions garlic and
tomatoes it's important to be as Johnson
that they be very aromatic and ripen
down the vine neutral magazine Gordon
the tomatoes are the basis for the sauce
and in fact the entire dish if the
tomatoes don't taste good the whole dish
won't taste good you have to make sure
then all green that they're juicy and
they smell good like ripe tomatoes
tomato back at Janish to be a fee on
s'en first slices the bacon the original
Italian recipe calls for guanciale but
pancetta or another streaky bacon can be
substituted for it
the bacon garlic onion and tomatoes have
to be finely diced the tomato skins can
be left on or removed according to taste
it'll Martin if you cook the tomatoes
whole it takes too long and you get a
lot more taste with a larger surface
area and the over flaky goes us pour
olive oil in a pan and saute the bacon
onions and garlic until they're
transparent then add the tomatoes then
briefly turn up the heat stirring the
whole time until you get a creamy
somewhat thicker consistency season with
salt and pepper to taste
then place the fresh spaghetti noodles
in boiling water for three or four
minutes until they're al dente dry
noodles take a few minutes longer
finally dress the plate sprinkle the
dish with freshly grated pecorino cheese
and it's ready to serve Marcus oh yeah
no but I like this dish very much
because it's easy and still delicious it
doesn't always have to be high-end
cuisine that's not what cooking's about
the emphasis should be on the natural
simplicity of the ingredients for one
year patrons of janish and other
participating restaurants can order
spaghetti all'amatriciana for a good
cause so far the restaurant josh has
raised about 200 euros to be sent to the
Italian red cross and hopes there will
be much more to come